so like you i am passionately in favor
of innovation innovation is the thing
that moves the human race forward
the single if you look at all the
research about innovation
all serious innovation requires deep
thought it requires periods of mind
wandering it requires really sustained
focus and attention so if you're in
favor of innovation as we both are
passionately
the thing you most want to get right is
attention because humans who can't pay
attention can't innovate right if you if
you can only think in 65 second bursts
good luck thinking of something new
right you'll never get there so if i
think about all the really impressive
innovators i've ever met from oprah to
noam chomsky
they are people who make space to think
deeply to really properly pay attention
so i think
and i wanted to just go back to
something you mentioned before i also
really want to talk about childhood
because i'm really fascinated you've got
an eight-year-old and i think this is
there's specific elements that are
destroying our children's attention that
i think will really vibe with the
solutions will really vibe with you but
let's think about sleep because you
mentioned that a few times in exhaustion
right
so we are in the united states a
chronically sleep-deprived society only
15 of us wake up feeling refreshed it
was one of the weirdest things that
happened to me in provincetown when i
took those three months off
i remember one morning about a month in
i woke up
and i went into the kind of um kitchen i
was like i feel really weird what do i
feel and i couldn't place it and i
realized i had woken up and i wasn't
tired right it was the first time i
remember that happening to me in my
adult life because we live at such a
level of exhaustion 40 of americans are
chronically sleep deprived so i
interviewed loads of the leading
scientists on sleep people at harvard
medical school and other places and
there was a few bits of science that
really threw me on this if you stay
awake for 19 hours which sounds like
nothing right 19 hours
you will be as your attention
deteriorates as badly as if you got
legally drunk
there was one experiment done by a guy
called dr charles seisler i interviewed
at harvard medical school
he put together two forms of technology
there's a technology that can track your
eyes to see what you're looking at and
there's a technology we all know about
that can scan your brain so he gets
tired people and he puts them into this
machinery and what he discovered was a
complete head [ __ ]
you can be awake you can be looking
around you can appear to be as awake as
you and me but whole parts of your brain
kind of gone to sleep right you know we
use that phrase i'm half asleep turns
out that's not a metaphor a lot of us
are literally half asleep a lot of the
time and this is so important because
professor roxanne prichard who's at the
university of minneapolis explained to
me a lot that um
that when you're sleeping your brain is
repairing it's healing itself so
throughout the day something called
metabolic waste builds up in your brain
it's what she calls brain cell poop
right and when you sleep your cerebral
spinal fluid channels open up and a kind
of water rinses through your brain and
it clears out all this [ __ ] that builds
up during the day
if you don't sleep properly if you don't
get eight hours sleep a night which
feels like a luxury to a lot of people
in the united states if you don't sleep
eight hours a night your brain does not
clean itself this is why people who
sleep less are far more likely to get
dementia you literally build up with
[ __ ] in your brain your attention will
be much worse you know that kind of
hungover feeling you have when you're
tired it turns out that's because your
brain is literally clogged up so the
single best thing you can do for your
attention along with exercises an
individual personal level
is get more sleep right um so yeah the
science on this is really clear and i'm
pretty shocking that there are some and
it sounds like you might be one of them
there's a there's some natural genetic
variation in terms of how much sleep
people need and some people are really
lucky and just naturally need less sleep
but that it's quite a small part of the
population and some people are unlucky
and need a shit-ton i actually agree
with you i i agree with you that you
know the more more
and by the way even the bodybuilding
world this gentleman you spoke to that
said sleeping helps with men's like
you're taking a mental [ __ ] like you
you're releasing all the toxins you know
out of your body phrase mental [ __ ]
that's the name of the book so so
you know the same thing happens when
you're sleeping your muscles don't grow
when you're working out your muscles
grow when you rest your muscles when
you're sleeping your muscles are grown
so i can actually see that so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]